hey Owen  yeah about New Year's Pam please water  under the bridge  honestly it's been a while  who's one setting your hair I'm going to  quick cuts I've got some time I can give  it like a quick trim yeah oh nothing  that's a good idea  we were pretty toxic for each other last  time around just make sure there's lots  of diet soda isn't there  I will could you know I drink them like  water I know except that's just an  expression because I hate water can't  stand the taste of it water doesn't have  any taste that's what I hate about it  except I don't really like the taste of  diet soda either really yeah I just  drink it because it's low in calories  he's an awful aftertaste  you